COUPLE HOURS AGO JAMES COMEY
ABOUT THE CLINTON SERVER
INVESTIGATION.
HE IS THE AUTHOR OF THE BEST
SELLING BOOK VENGEANCE,
FORMER SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE
FOX NEWS CONTRIBUTOR NEWT
GINGRICH.
OKAY, THIS IS MAY,
MR. SPEAKER.
HE HADN'T INTERVIEWED
HILLARY CLINTON OR AT LEAST
17 OTHERS KEY TO THE
I DON'T KNOW ANY OTHER WAY
TO IN.
I THINK THIS IS
UNBELIEVABLE.
IF WE BOTH SAT DOWN TWO
SETS OUT TO PROTECT HILLARY
CLINTON, NO MATTER HOW
GUILTY SHE IS.
EVEN HIS STATEMENTS IN
PUBLIC WILL EXONERATE HER.
IT IS NOW CLEAR, FIRST OF
EARLY ENOUGH, YOU PROBABLY
WOULD HAVE HAD BERNIE
SANDERS AS THE NOMINEE
BECAUSE HILLARY COULDN'T
HAVE SURVIVED THE OBVIOUS
NEWS.
>> Sean: THE FIX WAS IN.
>> ABOUT HOW GUILTY SHE AND
HER STAFF WERE.
>> Sean: TALK ABOUT THE
CLINTONS THE FIX WAS IN
THERE TOO WE NOW KNOW.
WE KNOW THE FIX WAS IN.
>> HERE'S MY POINT.
THIS IS A VERY SERIOUS
QUESTION FOR THE CONGRESS.
AND, FRANKLY, I THINK IT
PUTS AN ENORMOUS AMOUNT OF
PRESSURE ON THE ATTORNEY
GENERAL.
BECAUSE I THINK ATTORNEY
GENERAL SESSIONS HAS AN
ABSOLUTE OBLIGATION TO LOOK
AT THIS INFORMATION AND
COMEY AND HOW THEY ARE GOING
TO PROSECUTE ALL OF THESE
MESSAGES BACK AND FORTH.
AND INCLUDING, BY THE WAY, I
THINK, A GREAT DEAL OF HIS
YET UNREPORTED GUILT IN
TERMS OF THE CHIEF DEPUTY
HOS WIFE HAD
WHS WIFE HAD
WHOSWIFE HAD
WHOSEIFE HAD
WHOSE WE HAD
WHOSE WIFHAD
WHOSE WIFEAD
WHOSE WIFE HAD GOTTEN $900
FROM THE DEMOCRATS AND STILL
ENGAGED IN.
THIS HAVE YOU HERE ASSESS
POOL OF CORRUPTION, COVERING
UP FOR THE CLINTONS IN A WAY
WHICH I WOULD HAVE TO AS A
HISTORIAN SUN IMAGINABLE.
I DO NOT KNOW AT ANY POINT
IN AMERICAN HISTORY WHERE
YOU HAVE THIS LEVEL OF A
SYSTEM OF CORRUPTION.
WE HAVE HAD OCCASIONAL
ATTORNEY GENERALS.
WE HAD ONE UNDER HARDING.
WE HAD ONE UNDER GRANT.
BUT THIS LEVEL OF CONSTANT
METHODICAL UNDERMINING OF
THE RULE OF LAW?
PEOPLE WHO THOUGHT IT WAS
ABOUT LAW ENFORCEMENT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE, YOU ARE
TALKING ABOUT SOMETHING VERY
SCARY.
SOMETHING WHICH TOTALLY
UNDERMINES THE AMERICAN
SYSTEM.
>> Sean: MR. SPEAKER, I WANT
TO GET INTO THE SPECIFICS OF
DEEPER THAN WATERGATE EVER
WAS HERE, THERE IS
CORRUPTION AT THE HIGHEST
IT'S MOVABLE FACT THAT THE
FIX WAS IN HERE.
YOU HAVE JAMES COMEY.
THEN YOU HAVE THE
PRO-HILLARY ANTI-TRUMP PETER
STRZOK AND THEN HIS
GIRLFRIEND LISA PAGE, YEAH,
THIS EXONERATION OF HILLARY
CLINTON, WHEN YOU TAKE OUT
THE WORD LIKELY FOREIGN
UP A FOREIGN A NATIONAL
THE ACTUAL LEGAL LANGUAGE
GROSS NEGLIGENCE AND REMOVE
THAT AND PUT IN AND TRY TO
BE CUTE AND PUT IN EXTREME
CARELESSNESS, I DON'T EVEN
KNOW WHAT TO SAY.
I MEAN, THERE IS -- WOULDN'T
YOU DEFINE THIS AS
OBSTRUCTION?
SORRY.
JUSTICE.
IT IS VIOLATING THE LAW.
IT'S VERY LIKELY ALL OF
THESE PEOPLE WILL END UP
GOING TO JAIL.
BUT, IMAGINE THAT THE
ALLOWED THE LAW TO FOLLOW
ITS NATURAL COURSE.
IMAGINE THAT YOU HAD GOTTEN
A REPORT LAST SUMMER, THE
SUMMER OF 2016 BY DIRECTOR
COMEY SAYING, WELL, YOU
KNOW, IT'S LIKELY THAT
WAY SHE HAD HANDLED THEM AND
THE WAY SHE HAD BROKEN THE
RULES.
IT IS CLEAR THAT SHE WAS
GUILTY OF GROSS NEGLIGENCE,
WHICH, IN FACT, IS AS A
TECHNICAL TERM MEANING THAT
SHE HAD BROKEN THE LAW.
AND IF HE HAD SAID,
THEREFORE, I AM RECOMMENDING
THAT SHE BE PROSECUTED, I
MEAN, YOU WOULD HAVE BLOWN
THE WHOLE CAMPAIGN WIDE OPEN
AT THAT POINT.
YOU PROBABLY WOULD HAVE HAD
TRUMP WINNING WITH 55 OR 60
PIERCE OF THE VOTED.
YOU WOULD HAVE HAD A
SHATTERING OF THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY.
ALL OF THIS IS -- I
LITERALLY AND I WILL
WHERE YOU HAVE THIS KIND OF
METHODICAL CORRUPTION.
THIS VIOLATION OF THE RULE
OF LAW AT THIS LEVEL OF
BUREAUCRACY.
THEIR CAREER WHO ARE SWORN
TO UPHOLD THE LAW.
AND I THINK IT'S MAYBE THE
GREATEST CRISIS IN TERMS OF
LAW AND ORDER AND THE RULE